do you think that the public school
system based on everything that you've
seen is it hopelessly broken is it
salvageable I don't think so I think it
has be destroyed and rebuilt from the
ground it is so much worse than anyone
realizes I mean I'm like I'm one person
I have an account I post a bunch of
posts a day you post about this stuff
there are other accounts that post about
it but we're limited we we can't we
can't be sharing every single thing we
come across I obviously do a lot of
research into this topic and it is a
thousand times worse than anyone even
realizes that it's it's worse than I can
ever even have time to discuss and to
and to post about